ahh.... J'ai trop souffert !
tous ces jeux rageant là
*tousse*
Ahhh !!
putain !
ça m'a flingué le cerveau, j'ai plus envie de vivre vous comprenez et le marteau a fait déborder le chaudron.
Les amis après tant d'heures de souffrance a passé sur ces putain de jeux vidéo challengeant.
Aujourd'hui j'ai besoin d'un peu de calme un peu
de repos du coup on va jouer au jeu le plus facile du monde c'est comme ça qu'ils appellent en plus en combo y'a un petit
chat pour nous indiquer que ses gentils, bienveillant tout ça.
Attends, j'espère que c'est pas du mito et que c'est vraiment un jeu facile, hein ?
Si c'est un jeu rageant c'est la que, heu...
je vais péter un câble.
je suis ''Queasy cat'' en raison d'une condition malheureuse je ne peux pas supporter la vue une question difficile
mec, ça m'arrange énormément !
comme moi tu auras neuf vies et seulement 9.
Attend mec y'a une histoire de vie c'est que c'est pas facile.
''Avec qu'elle maintient tient-tu ta cuillère ?''
"la main gauche ou la main droite ou aucune des deux." Dans le cas où tu as subi un très
grave accident tu dirais "aucune des deux" mais normalement c'est la main gauche
"Les gens riches l'ont et les gens pauvres l'ont aussi."
C'est très très connu malheureusement pour toi et c'est "rien".
"Voici mon chien bleu de quelle couleur est mon chien ?"
Mais attend c'est trop connu ça, c'est avec un cheval même la langue française qu'on a fait cette vanne.
"Quelle est la couleur du cheval blanc d'Henri IV" et ben si tu mets vert tu te trompe pas ce qui les bleu !
"Attend 12 secondes" ça normalement...
Au le bâtard est plus il mets une pub c'est incroyable, le chien !
Mais mec ! c'est pas du tout simple c'est incroyable..
"lequel sont les états unis ?"
"OK gens malin mais de quel état il s'agit ?"
Mais mec c'est des...
je suis français espèce de bâtard !
le nouveau mexique
"ida ou rhode island ou le texas"
la forme laisse penser d une vague une vague l inverse du texas étonné que le texas est très sec
c'est peut-être la réaction qu'il faut avoir dans le cadre il veut nous induire en erreur
mais rhodes island part d'une île. il est forcément autour et tout cela pour être la bonne réponse.
c'est bien sure l'île
"combien de coupe il y at-il dans un quart ?"
Un quart de litre !
Un quart de litre c'est une demi pinte une demi pinte
qu'est ce que je raconte là ?
OK, une demi-tasse ses douze centilitres donc deux tasses et douze centilitres fois deux faute deet 24 centimes ce qui
donne un cadre de litres donc dans un cas
combien de quart y at-il dans un gallon alors ça oui parce que tu es sont parlants gallon pour les sources 1 gallon ça fait
3785 millilitres d'eau consent-il tafer
combien font deux plus deux plus sept moins sept ? 2 + 2 = 4 + 7 = 11 - 7 = 4
Combien de côté un
Un square a t'il
Putain d'anglais de merde un carré ta tête quand tu réalises que square peut dire car et il y en a quatre
Mais je suis content mais je suis content ça me fait du bien combien de côté possède un rectangle
moi ça va aussi tu vas pas nous la faire foi oui combien de pâtes un chien possède 4
si tu prends la moitié du wave voiture mon cas je suis sérieux à l'âge de me concentrer si tu coupes la moitié de la
jambe d'une araignée parce que tu es cruel combien de jambes
va-t-il rester à l'araignée à ce moment précis je ne me rends pas compte de la gravité de mon erreur j'ai en fait mal gratuits
d'annoncés if you take the spiders lives of ne veut pas dire si tu retires la moitié d'une jambe d'une araignée mais veut dire si
tu retires la moitié des gens d'une araignée la suite vous la connaissez
Combien y at-il de saison dans une année à on est bien
Combien de doigts y at il sur une main humaine
à combien de questions as-tu répondu
Atteinte en fausse conscience vous présentait il y avait l'histoire des pays y avait l'histoire de l'araignée il avait l'histoire du calcul est l histoire
du nombre de saisons dans une année juste deux ou trois autres je dirais 10
Est ce qu'une grenouille cogne sont derrière par terre quand elle saute
Bah apparemment non
J'ai perdu
est ce que c'est le jeu puissantes du monde oui
ok on est bien jusque là tout va bien est ce que l'os est en train de faire ses besoins dans les bois se trouve
là il est juste assis sur un tabouret mecque et ils attendent le bus et le pq qui est là se trouve la même pas
vu c'est peut-être juste des gens frustrés combien pq sur la branche parce qu'ils voulaient voir un cadavre comme logan paul pour le film est
alors non putain mais moi je suis trop habitués à notre quiz et tous ta faute tu paies incomber à de lapin
J'ai pris mon temps pour compter ce temps là là je le prends même pas pour méditer tous les jours ou pour faire le point
sur ma situation familiale appuyez sur le bouton
Joue peu avec mes nerfs
Qu'est-ce que tu mets dans un toaster du pain harris
mais putain mais tu es là quand je prends le petit déj?!
Bat moi au morpion alors là mec t'as pas de change pas sa
vision de ce qu'il va faire ça pour gagner c'est très simple j'ai gagné
Je vais faire comme les mecs dans la forêt pour exprimer mon mécontentement
je vais mettre un pq
Quel état est-ce?
Ça  représente du gel, là où il fait très froid c'en en Ontario.
ce raisonnement est nuls à chier
jeu de mots: la couleur du soleil tôt le matin c'est orange et en plus à un mot transparence
et orange c'est comme le soir tard ne me dites pas que j'ai faux
Ok vous venez d'assister
qui coûte cher sa colère mais ça devait me faire du bien
voici mon chien bleu de quelle couleur est mon chien
mais après ils changent de couleur dès que je vais sur une couleur
ah c'était ça le piège du coup il est vert
yes est ce que cette lune est faite de fromage
oui a priori
tu as 5 kendy barre dans un bol qui en retire 3 combien de kendy barre il te reste
ça dépend tout est une question de point de vue alors là il ya débat est-ce que le bol
t'appartient ou pas s'il bolt appartient et le reste dans le vol donc il en reste deux mais si le vol n'est pas à toi
ça veut dire que c'est toi qu'on a pris 3 pour les mettre dehors donc les trois sont à toi on va part du principe
Que le bol est à nous
Est ben voilà au putain dalmatiens combien y en a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
12 13 14 15 16 17 j'ai passé huit heures sur cette question mais je vais avoir bon ça je vous le dis
bread, bread
ok il ya un petit avion qui s'est crashé
et chaque personne est mort combien de personnes ont survécu tout le monde parce que personne n'était à bord
ah c'est ça la blague on en est là dans ce jeu
c'est bien alors assez un pan du hockey lui manque qu'une jambe comme l'araignée d'ailleurs alors uni manque une demi jambes ou une jambe hobbes
je ne me rends pas compte que cette black ne marche pas du tout car je ne me rends toujours pas compte que j'avais mal
traduit l'énoncé je suis un vrai looser castle
gaza y tu marches dans un restaurant dans la pièce il y a dix personnes qui ont 21 ans trois personnes qui ont 26 107
personnes qui ont 29 ans et neuf personnes qui ont 31 ans y en a dix sept qui sont des garçons
combien de gens ya dans le restaurant
ok il attire notre attention sur des détails alors fallu juste retenir le clip de base à savoir combien de gens rien si l'on connaît
bien
homme est témoin des gifles
Voilà et m'explique pas la blague voilà comme ça je suis sûr d'avoir faut quand je recommence trouve une partie du corps qui peut se
faire de la même manière à l'endroit et à l'envers
bas à coude coutts a fait et donc je mets un coup des doutes
ok what is the number between moines en dessous c'est un nombre décimal ouais mais vu que c'est un anglais
c'est pas vrai non mais j'en ai marre premier comme si le car on avait dit que
ta mère la slip
alice à 14 sur ça y est la saison la fin soit la question quel âge a glissé bah voila voila tiens ton plus
quel est ton nom
le cas
royal à combien de questions at il répondu à 9 ses marques elle a en fait on à gauche
quel pays est le plus grand
l'angleterre où les unes est des états unis les états unis et a juste fait une petite hume qui tombe de cheval est ce que
tu es sûr mais c'est quoi cette question est non
ah ah
ah bah oui c'est la bonne réponse je n'étais pas sûr de la réponse
c'est bien la décimale bah oui c'est incorrect parce que tu es un jeu anglais était raciste nombre décimal
décimales nommera putain je validais je pars je la passe et a marché
Regarde cette scène tu ne pourra la voir qu'une fois observe bien ça va être en tous cas en avoir c'est sûr priscille bloqués
Tout
Jean john tiens ta grosse mer j'ai regardé que ça leur passe qu'il est avec j'ai faim quelle était la couleur du sofa
C'était du reste et violet yes haye c'était la maison qui
crise qui crissent l'otan
yes we do better 14 hommes mec j'ai les deux on va dire un chat
the world swim si le cmt for adhd mba croire james adam smith
Je n'en peux plus c'en est trop pour moi c'est ça le début
2018 s'est joué à un jeu facile qui reviennent des pins jeu facile après tant d'efforts tant d'heures passées à se battre pour passer les
jeux les plus durs ben non monsieur ça se passera pas comme ça
s'il ya bien un truc que j'ai appris dans la vie c'est qu'il faut persévérer pour y arriver alors on va persévérer
Gens
dormez vous tord vous
savez
et ça 10 et
Oubliez tout ce que je veux dire on s'en bat les couilles
persévérer jamais dans la vie opposé à celui des losers douce et amère aller l'aca luxe
ça